welcome to an extended solo episode of
our podcast my name is Kashi and today
we'll embark on a deep and meaningful
Journey Through The Complex landscape of
Teen Mental Health in high
school this is a personal and in-depth
exploration as I share insights stories
and strategies to help you navigate the
challenges of high school while prioriti
prioritizing your mental well-being so
let's get
started High School is a crucial phase
in a young person's life I'll begin by
setting the stage providing an overview
of the academic social and emotional
aspects that Define this significant
period many teenagers carry hidden
struggles from Stress and
Anxiety to depression and self-doubt in
this segment I'll shed a light on these
hidden challenges and why it's a
essential to acknowledge
them academic pressure can be
overwhelming we'll exp explore the
academic
stresses their impact on mental health
and practical strategies to find a
balance between between success and
well-being High School is a complex
social environment
where PE peer relationships and peer
pressure and the influence of social
media play a significant role in shaping
self-esteem and mental health will D
delve into these
Dynamics coping with the challenges of
high school is vital I'll share various
coping mechanisms and resilience
building Strate strategies to help you
navigate stress and
adversity asking for asking for help is
a sign of strength in this segment we'll
discuss the importance of seeking
support from
friends family or mental health
professionals I'll offer guidance or
initiating the these essential
conversations
so another part is personal
stories or of
resilience personal stories from
individuals who face teen mental health
challenges during high school can be
both inspiring and informative I'll
share some of the stories of to
highlight the power of
resilience I've received questions from
our listeners and I'll take a moment to
address a few of these questions o
offering insights and
guidance the path forward we have p uh
so many paths to finish high school well
self-care for example self-care is not
just a buzz word is necessary I'll
emphasize the importance of self-care
and of to offer practical suggestions
for creating s s
sustainable PR practices that support
your mental
health another one is balancing
academics and
well-being striking a balance between
academic excellence and mental
well-being is
possible I'll provide detailed strategy
strategies and insights to help you
navigate high school without
compromising your mental
health You Are Not
Alone on this journey there's a
community and
numerous resources available to support
you I'll introduced some of the
resources and organizations dedicated to
to Teen Mental
Health resilience is a powerful tool
too in overcoming challenges I'll
explore the concept of
resiliences and why it's
essential and how to develop and nurture
this and nurture this strength within
yourself the importance of mindfulness
and
self-reflection mind fulness and
self-reflection can be transformative
practices I'll discuss the role in
improving mental health and provide
practical tips to incorporate them in in
your daily
life final thoughts and encouragement as
we reach the end of this ex
Exquisite episode I want to leave you
with a heartfelt message of of
encouragement so just so you know you
are stronger than you know and you can
overcome the challenges of high school
while safeguarding your mental health
remember that help is available and your
journey is
important
so I just said this so you won't forget
what I what I made on this podcast what
I said so don't forget so I just want to
thank you
for a
accom
accompaning me on this deep exploration
of Teen Mental Health in high school if
this episode has res
res resonated with you or you believe it
could benefit others please consider
sharing
it as you continue your high school
Journey always remember that
you you're well-being matters you matter
and you have the capacity to shape it in
a positive way take care be kind to
yourself and and know that you're not
alone on this journey go stay with the
right people go to professionals if you
need them you have your family by your
side you have your friends by your side
you can do this you matter your mental
health matters your well-being matters
so seek help it won't show uh that
you're weak it will show that you're
strong it will show that you you want it
you mean it you want to make a change so
thank you very much for listening me
listening to me in this podcast in this
episode so have have a fun have a nice
day and remember you matter and your
wellbe and your well being matters thank
you very much until next
time